[MUSIC PLAYING]
There's a new Black Panther
with a new look in Marvel
Studios' "Black Panther--
Wakanda Forever."
So to get the scoop
on the suit, I'm
talking with Marvel Studios
head of visual development Ryan
Meinerding.
Hi, Ryan.
Hello.
Well, let's jump in.
Shuri's new Black Panther
suit is an incredible take
on an already iconic suit, so as
you started work on this film,
how did you approach
this new design?
RYAN MEINERDING: One of the
great things about Shuri
in the first "Black Panther"
movie was that she had, like,
pretty amazing iconic
looks across the board,
some that Ruth
Carter designed, some
that the visual
development team designed.
We were trying to
look at pretty early
on with how to translate
some of those things
into the Black Panther suit.
And I think with Shuri, we
were trying to find almost
a slightly more fierce look.
I think we were trying to
evolve her into a character
where she was stepping into
the mantle in a way that was
tremendously her own
and that involved
becoming a sort of more fierce
version of Black Panther.
It's such an awesome design.
What were some of the key
visual elements you and the team
were looking to incorporate?
In terms of the overall
aesthetic of the suit,
it's kind of the same
as the other Panther
suits where we're trying to
make it as skintight to her body
as possible so it
feels flexible.
It feels like she
can be acrobatic.
She can be strong and powerful.
It doesn't have to have any sort
of restrictions on her at all.
You know, one of the things
that Ryan Coogler had asked
for is sort of maybe even
weaponry or, you know,
starting with her Panther
gauntlets becoming even larger
or because she is, you know,
obviously a technology expert,
the tech became added on
and those things got bulkier
and almost made
the suit look more
powerful through
having technology
as part of a visual language.
But as we got into
it we did realize
we had so many amazing visual
reference points from Shuri
in the previous movie that
we were kind of hearkening
back to those a lot.
I think the biggest
sort of change
in the suit in the
previous designs
is fundamentally the boldness
of the design language
as well as the Panther gauntlets
and a few pieces of gold
around her shoulders that
are a little bit stronger
and meant to give
her a little bit more
of a shoulder
silhouette than she
would have had without them.
Well, you packed so many
amazing details into this suit.
How many iterations
of Shuri's suit
did the team create before
settling on the final design?
We probably had 50 or
60 different designs.
I think there was a lot
of really amazing things
to play with, and having
the comics as a base
but also having those
amazing appearances
in the first movie
as a place to start
was basically where we began.
I think we ended up
landing on one that
had that sort of fierce look
with things that represented
Panther teeth both on the
top and bottom of her jaw
and specifically
pulling from her warrior
falls look where she had
a number of white dots
painted on her face.
We were trying to turn those
into sort of graphic elements
that are done in silver, and
then finding all those things
integrated into
one cohesive look
was one of the more fun
parts of the process.
And, again, bringing that
gold and silver in to sort of
say that she's now at
a place where she's
stepping into the
mantle, taking on all
of the burden of where
her country is at
and trying to save the day.
Now, of course, Shuri
isn't the first person
we've seen take on the
mantle of the Black Panther.
Are there any parts
of this design
that referenced previous
Black Panther suits?
One of the fun things about
Marvel Studios and Marvel
comics is that there
are characters that
have these sort of mantles
that can get passed
from one character to another.
That symbol of
that mantle becomes
different and changed in some
way when the new character
takes it over.
The suits that we start with
end up meaning something,
and then how they translate into
the next film and the next film
all seem to like become useful
in the storytelling going
forward.
And when we were working on the
Black Panther suit for "Civil
War," that ended
up being sort of
termed sort of T'Challa's suit.
I think in the "Black Panther"
movie where T'Challa explains
to Shuri that was
what he had developed,
and Shuri creates that suit
in "Black Panther," right.
And Killmonger ends up
taking that gold suit
and sort of making it his
own at the end of that film.
Essentially, the suit
that Shuri ends up with
is kind of a combination
between T'Challa's
suit and Killmonger's suit, a
mix of the silver and the gold.
That's the Panther she needed
to become in order to be
able to fight Namor at the end.
There are some subtle nods
to each one of those suits
in the final design,
but it really
is as simple as the color
schemes being the silver
and the gold being
the two things.
There is a bit of through
line for her representing
her fallen brother
as well as probably
begrudgingly representing
things she needed
to learn from Killmonger.
So, Ryan, what
did it mean to you
to be able to
continue the legacy
of the Black Panther in the
MCU through a new character
and this new design.
RYAN MEINERDING:
The fact that we
were able to work on
Shuri in "Black Panther"
and to see her sort of
transition into a full on Black
Panther of her own
in "Black Panther--
Wakanda Forever," it was
an amazing experience.
Like, the idea of watching
that character take on a mantle
do things that she didn't think
she could do, try to live up
to her brother's
memory, for me, it's
to have been part of
this journey of watching
this character become beloved
by the audience and the fans
and trying to figure out how
Shuri can feel like she's
taking that mantle and
carrying it forward
was an incredible experience.
I am the Black Panther,
and I'm here for retribution.
Well, you and the
whole team really
did an amazing job, Brian.
Thank you so much
for talking with us.
Thank you.
It was great to be here.
Thank you so much.
LANGSTON BELTON: And, of course,
everyone go experience Marvel
Studios' "Black Panther--
Wakanda Forever"
in theaters now.